We're just a month away from the premiere
of Frozen II, and fans can't wait to see what
unfolds in the sequel to the beloved Disney
film.
Audiences are especially hopeful that the
film will finally reveal something many of
us have been wondering since Frozen was released
in 2013.
King Agnarr and Queen Iduna of Arendelle played
a small, but critical, role in Frozen.
At the beginning of the film, they hide a
young Elsa away in an attempt to control her
powers, putting a wedge between her and Anna.
Just a few scenes into the movie, they board
a ship, leaving their now-grown daughters
in Arendelle.
They're shipwrecked after being caught in
a storm, and the crown falls to Elsa.
Now, if Frozen II remains true to Disney formula
— which seems to, with few exceptions, leave
its protagonists either orphaned or with one
living parent — then Elsa and Anna's parents
are dead.
The Frozen II trailer that dropped in June,
however, makes us think that things might
be headed in another direction.
The trailer opens with Elsa growing into her
powers, battling tidal waves.
Underwater, she encounters a mythical Norse
water spirit called a Nokk.
Elsa and Anna then embark on a quest, urged
on by the troll Grand Pabbie who delivers
an ominous warning:
"Elsa.
The past is not what it seems."
We also see Queen Iduna in trailer footage.
Some fans have taken all of this to mean that
one or both of Elsa and Anna's parents are
still alive, and that one of them may have
powers of their own that enabled them to survive
the shipwreck.
There's also speculation that the water horse
was sent as a message to Elsa and Anna, to
tell them that the shipwreck hadn't been fatal.
This ties into other fan theories that came
out after Frozen's release.
One such theory speculates that Elsa and Anna's
parents might also be Tarzan's parents.
While the man and woman in Tarzan don't really
look like King Agnarr and Queen Iduna, Tarzan's
parents did end up stranded following a shipwreck.
Even Frozen's director, Chris Buck, said that
he likes this theory.
In Buck's imagination, King Agnarr and Queen
Iduna don't die.
He told MTV News that in his mind:
"They get shipwrecked, and somehow they really
washed way far away from the Scandinavian
waters, and they end up in the jungle.
They end up building a tree house and a leopard
kills them, so their baby boy is raised by
gorillas."
He also added:
"So in my little head, Anna and Elsa's brother
is Tarzan — but on the other side of that
island are surfing penguins, to tie in a non-Disney
movie, Surf's Up.
That's my fun little world."
Another favorite fan theory connects Elsa
and Anna's parents to The Little Mermaid and
Tangled.
Could the sunken ship we see in The Little
Mermaid actually belong to King Agnarr and
Queen Iduna?
According to this theory, Elsa and Anna's
parents were on their way to Rapunzel and
Flynn's wedding when their ship crashed, leaving
it for Ariel to one day explore.
From there, Rapunzel and Flynn feel guilty
for the deaths of Elsa and Anna's parents,
leading them to attend Elsa's coronation three
years later.
It's not a lot to go on, but the theories
and the trailer do give us some hope that
Elsa and Anna's parents survived the terrible
shipwreck.
Will Frozen II see the king and queen reunited
with Elsa and Anna, giving them a chance to
be a happy family with no more secrets between
them?
It's true that Disney has a habit of making
its princesses orphans, but Disney films are
even better known for their happy endings.
We'll have to wait until Frozen II premieres
on November 22 to find out for sure.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more The List videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.